it's a huge question to say what should
I write and I I do my best to answer
that in the easiest way for new writers
in my book and and I try to break that
down the best I can but I mean it's it's
a really big question and the thing I
certainly don't want to see any
screenwriters run into is just feeling
like they have to blindly guess I try to
answer that in the book but if you don't
have access to the book the best advice
I could give to a screen writer is what
that story is and and you know it's not
that cliche write what you know because
I've never written what I quote unquote
know I I write fantastical worlds and
and and and and supernatural stories and
all of that but write what you feel and
write what's in your heart and write
something that means something to you
you can go to a Redbox machine used to
be blockbuster but those all turned into
cell phone stores you can go to rex box
red box machine look at the independent
films on they're so independent would be
that the family titles at the bottom
look for the live-action ones usually
with a dog or an animal on them and then
also look at the big studio films that
are kind of you know throughout the
Machine you'll see them in different
spots whatever a big studio film is look
to the ones that are like right next to
that or get on Netflix and find a big
studio movie in lineup and then look at
the independent movie you've never heard
of that's next to it that's the
independent Hollywood zone that's where
I work those are the scripts that were
in need of that's that's where I think
you're going to get your best indicator
as to the genres that work the genre
themes you're going to see the number of
cast members the all that information I
was a script reader for God probably a
decade and I and the and and I was
reading seven eight scripts a week and
the rare one was the great script and
when you found that that was a very
exciting day at the office
and sometimes the really terrible
scripts were kind of they were fun
because they were so god-awful but the
ones that got really exhausting and
really entered
as a script reader who's sitting there
and has to read a script synopsize that
write a comment about it then pick up
another one and read it and so were the
ones that you could tell we're written
by people who were looking at what last
year's hit was and trying to imitate it
and those were deadly and they were they
weren't good they weren't bad they were
safe and mediocre and any writer any
young writer any old writer anyone who's
just starting to write anything write
something that you feel write write
write write something that comes from
the heart
I think screenwriters stand their best
chance of really getting noticed by
knowing what the business needs so it's
not coming in talking about how
passionate you are about the script it's
talking and speaking in a way that
answers to the needs of the production
company the producer of the studio etc
it's there are tried and tested genres
that are just they they just nail what
the business lives on and if you're if a
young writer wants to come into the
business and really just get their
emails answered get the phone calls
returned it's being able to speak about
their project and have it answer to
those things it's it's gonna be saying
I'm writing a family film about this I'm
writing a film about this and it's a
very quick point it's not it's you know
never coming-of-age stories it's never
dramas it's it's happier films it's it's
the kinds of films you see on a Redbox
machine that's what Hollywood needs to
stay in business and so if you're coming
to the table bringing opportunities for
Hollywood to continue staying in
business they're gonna pay attention to
you when I decided I was going to be a
writer again and decided I was going to
do it with Michael in my mind I said to
myself I sound so awful maybe but I'm
gonna write a classic well I'm not just
gonna write another movie we are going
to curry
a classic and who knows what that means
and again it sounds obnoxious maybe but
we knew probably I don't know 20-some
pages in that just something was
happening and we weren't thinking about
demographics we weren't thinking about
who the audience was going to be we
weren't thinking about any any
quote/unquote commercial aspects of it
we were thinking what's good what's
funny what's making us laugh what's
moving the story forward what are the
zany as craziest ideas we can have and
it just and it happens with with with
scripts and it happens in your writing
there's just times that you feel that
you're in a zone and you're in a place
that you're so connecting with yourself
and you're so connecting with what your
vision is that if you can get on a page
other people are gonna see it and feel
it and never at any point am I saying
don't write dramas don't write comedies
don't write the coming-of-age story if
you have a fantastic idea for a movie I
think a writer should hold on to just
hold on to it wait like get the
commercial scripts out first get a
reputation of being our screenwriter who
can deliver what the system needs who
can write quickly who can write well who
can write within budget and get a couple
of actual paid gigs and you'll get them
if you go in the opposite way saying I
know what Hollywood wants they want this
they want these very deep dramas
coming-of-age dramas and forcing them to
do that it's not you're not gonna get
noticed but if you come in giving them
what they want which are like tween girl
family films or christmas movies with
dogs women in peril thrillers these
kinds of things
Hollywood pays attention to you and once
you are writing those and once you're
getting noticed for that work then you
have a collection of contacts and you
can say I have an interesting idea
could this work and then you can present
those people may not think that
Beetlejuice is a personal movie it's an
intensely personal movie it was
intensely personal for Michael and me
and and you know I I didn't know I had a
theme until I had enough work to realize
I had a theme and almost everything I've
written are about broken families who
are put back together in some bizarre
way but there but but being because I
came from a broken family and and what
and and and so so there's a I like to
think that my work has a sense of heart
in a sense of compassion and a sense of
humanity in it no matter how bizarre it
is no matter how weird the world's get
and and you got you got to write
something that you feel on something
that you have some passion for or just
why do it it's too hard it's just it's
it's it's not an easy job I would take
the high school script over the foreign
exchange one hands down but I would take
it and we would probably rebrand that
and make it junior high and make it more
focused on a tween girl audience knowing
that 9 to 12 year old girls are the most
likely audience to be renting movies and
buying movies on something like iTunes
Amazon or other platforms and I would
see bigger numbers doing that and I'd
make a really nice pink poster see this
is how we're talking it's you come in
with an idea and then we target an
audience we know we need to hit and then
we we create a concept around that and I
can already see the key art in my head
and I would go talk to my teams about
doing that I know how much money we can
make internationally with a movie like
that and we would go then have either
take that writer and have them rewrite
it or we go hire a writer we've had
experience with to write the movie we
now just create it in two minutes
I personally can't imagine saying well
this was a hit now so I'm gonna I'm
gonna write my version and that I don't
really it's not really what I care about
what I feel but I can imitate it well
enough I can't
imagine spending a year of your life
doing that but people do it all the time
and they usually write me do Chris Krebs
is being safe something that's never
appealed to you I I don't know how in in
in in my career and in my life say safe
hasn't factored into it and and not not
always not always the best decisions
maybe but I'm just I sort of like
jumping off cliffs look comedies are
fantastic and and you would be correct
anyone would be correct if they said
comedies are very high grossing popular
movies they absolutely are the problem
is the best way for a new writer to
really break into Hollywood until the
career is to go towards the independent
space not the big studios there's too
much noise of the big studio level
there's way too many barriers so go to
Indy Hollywood that's where I work and
that's where really most of the movies
and content that's where it comes from
so on the comedies front Indy Hollywood
is not just thinking us in Canada we're
not thinking our domestic
english-speaking markets we're thinking
global we get a lot of our money from
overseas and the problem with most
newbie writers is they want to write
something like American Pie a really
raunchy comedy or they want to write a
very smart comedy with you know
high-level humor and and you know witty
dialogue witty dialogue cost a lot of
money to dub social nuances in Russia or
India or Japan or not what they are here
not every country in the world
celebrates Thanksgiving and understands
what the Super Bowl means there are
there are so many subtleties to the
international marketplace that even if
you nail your comedy script and make it
wide enough for an english-speaking
audience to understand that's a very
limited part of the world and the way
Hollywood executive or the way a
producer will read that is that's a very
limited cross-section of money and I'm
missing out on a lot of other revenue
that can come in so comedies are great
just keep them in your back pocket when
things are going well in my writing and
I think it's true for all writers that
if you're like intensely self-conscious
about who is your audience who who is it
you know is this for the 12 to 16 year
old if you're doing that you're not
writing well and you get in a zone and
your story starts telling you you're not
telling the story it's emerging from
some place within you and that's what
Beetlejuice was and I just always had
and I used to say to Michael sometimes
because I could feel it going well and
I'd say Michael you know we're gonna
have a toy lining he'd go shut up shut
up let's just finish the script you know
but III mean it's a very hard thing to
explain what that what that what that
it's it's a it's an epiphany after
enough if any and that you feel like
you're just onto something bigger than
you out of all the spec scripts in
Hollywood the reason it's not made to
fruition it's just people writing the
wrong thing so it's there's so many my
view is this it's like there's the
stereotype in Hollywood that there's
there's every every other waiter you
meet is like has a screenplay on the
side every real estate agents writing
something on the side and in truth like
that that's reality a lot of people come
here with big Hollywood dreams and want
to write that great screenplay and
people just kind of go oh well you know
they're not talented they're writing bad
scripts certainly there's a lot of bad
scripts but at the same time there's a
lot of very talented people who just
aren't writing the right things so
they're not writing the right things
they're not writing what Hollywood needs
and they're not presenting their work in
the way that it needs to be presented to
get doors to open so if they just shift
a few of those elements if they write
what Hollywood needs which are goldmine
genres as we outline in the book if they
if they present their ideas in a way
Hollywood needs to hear them which is
about pitching your story in a way that
is this is how my script helps your
company this is how my script answers
that that need in the Hollywood system
and then if you just kind of get
yourself out there at the same time like
that's how you really do it it's
building it's not it's not selling a
one-off script it's building a career